[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia del cob y 19 soy santiago lópez
gonzález a continuación les presento los
principales temas de esta visión
brasilia superó la barrera de los 400
mil fallecidos por kobe 19 este país
sigue siendo el foco de la pandemia a
nivel mundial y parece que son pocas las
medidas adoptadas para mitigar el avance
de el coronavirus mientras tanto en eeuu
el gobierno autorizó que las personas
que ya están vacunadas pueden obviar el
uso de la mascarilla si están en
espacios abiertos y con poca
concurrencia también daremos un vistazo
a la crítica situación de colombia más
de 10 días consecutivos con más de 400
víctimas mortales diarias y miles de
contagiados nuevos cada día con nuestro
asesor científico el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez hablaremos de las
características de la variante de india
ya presente en 17 países y que tiene en
emergencia precisamente a la india en
ese en el continente asiático con un
rebrote que hasta ahora parece ser
incontrolable para las autoridades
hablaremos también de las demás vacunas
que están en desarrollo y que podríamos
encontrar en el mercado y hablaremos de
una en particular sobre todo ese
rifirrafe entre brasil y rusia por la
vacuna
y también hablaremos de la relación
entre el embarazo y la vacunación y por
último hablaremos de los anuncios hechos
por la organización mundial de la salud
que alberto que la vacunación de
enfermedades como polio también como el
sarampión que son potencialmente
mortales está siendo descuidada por
darle prioridad a la vacunación del
joven 19la o ms también alertó esta
semana que en los últimos días la
pandemia del cobi 19 se ha acelerado y
por eso hace un llamado para el acceso
equitativo de las vacunas y las medidas
de prevención indispensables para evitar
más casos también hablaremos de la
situación en costa rica y en perú con
nuestros corresponsales estos son
algunos de los temas tenemos muchos más
comenzamos a pensar les decía yo en el
avance que la cifra destacada de la
semana es una cifra lamentable y son los
más de 400.000 fallecidos que deja la
pandemia en brasil en lo que va corrido
del año la cifra exacta para el cierre
de esta semana es de 401 mil 186
personas fallecidas la mayoría de ellos
están en los estados de sao paulo río de
janeiro minas gerais
rio grande do sul también en paraná y en
bayas
es crítica la situación en brasil sigue
siendo un foco de importancia un foco
muy importante para la pandemia ya lo
decíamos 400.000 fallecidos y por esa
cifra volvió a captar la atención
internacional vamos a conocer más
detalles con valeria saccone desde la
ciudad de río de janeiro valeria en
medio de toda esta situación que se está
presentando en algo positivo y es el
avance que ha tenido la vacuna que está
desarrollando el laboratorio butantán
que ya pasa a una nueva fase que más
detalles hay
pero ha empezado esta semana a producir
su propia vacuna se llama bután back es
un proyecto del instituto butantán que
son uno de los centros de investigación
más importantes de brasil es público
está en el estado de san paulo y en este
momento es responsable de envasar la
corona back la vacuna importada desde
china que corresponde al 84 por ciento
de las dosis aplicadas hasta ahora la
producción inicial es pequeña un millón
de dosis con la idea de llegar a 18
millones de dosis en junio y
eventualmente hay también una capacidad
anual de 100 millones de dosis de
momento la agencia del medicamento la
anvisa no ha dado el ok todavía para
hacer los ensayos en humanos y ha pedido
más detalles al instituto butantán pero
si todo se hace como se prevé en brasil
podría pasar de importar las vacunas a
ser un productor y podría vacunar para
finales de este año toda superpoblación
de 212 millones de personas como hoy ha
prometido el nuevo ministro de sanidad y
también podría exportar
las vacunas a los países vecinos
valeria en brasil la vacunación está
avanzando muy lentamente y es necesario
que este país adquiera más lotes de
vacunas y de diferentes vacunas pero
hubo un rifirrafe entre brasil y rusia
por la adquisición de la vacuna sputnik
bay que es elaborada en rusia y se
convirtió prácticamente en un choque
diplomático
polémica en brasil sobre la vacuna rusa
nick de esa semana a la agencia del
medicamento la vida la ha rechazado
alegando que la documentación presentada
por los fabricantes rusos es incompleta
y poco transparente hay muchas razones
técnicas entre ellas dudas sobre el
adenovirus se utilizado como vector para
introducir una partícula de comida en el
cuerpo humano parece que se ha de nobiru
si se multiplica de forma descontrolada
y según los técnicos de la anvisa
representaría un peligro para la salud
los fabricantes rusos temen que haya
motivaciones políticas detrás de esta
decisión y amenazan con ir a los
tribunales pero la anvisa niega mientras
tanto los 14 estados brasileños que
estaban negociando directamente con
rusia se quedan sin vacuna contaban con
30 millones de dosis y ahora con más de
400.000 muertos en brasil la situación
es cada vez más nebulosa por otra parte
una buena noticia esta semana también
llegaron a brasil las primeras dosis de
lava
para ser
valeria no puedo dejar de preguntarle
por otra noticia importante de esta
semana y es esa comisión creada en el
congreso de brasil para investigar al
presidente y hay revolucionarios y
algunos funcionarios de su gobierno por
sus omisiones a lo largo de los cuidados
que debían haber tomado a lo largo de
toda esta pandemia de kobe y 19 cuáles
son esas omisiones por parte del
mandatario
esta semana también ha arrancado la
comisión de investigación de la pandemia
en el senado entre muchas polémicas para
muchos analistas es una derrota para el
presidente de brasil jair bolsonaro que
se opuso a su instalación e incluso
intentó desvirtuar su contenido
intentando que investigarse la actuación
de los gobernadores y de los alcaldes
cosa que no puede hacer según la
constitución del senado
el relator escogido de sherman caliero
es un senador de vieja generación que
considerado un enemigo de bolsonaro de
hecho en su discurso de inauguración
dijo que hay que poner cuanto antes a
los responsables de tantas muertes en
brasil renan calheiros ya ha presentado
una posible calendario de trabajo se
trabaja con seis líneas de investigación
la principal es apurar las
responsabilidades del gobierno federal
en la gestión de la pandemia es decir
sin bolsonaro y sólo lo suficiente para
evitar tantas muertes hemos sabido
además que se va a utilizar
un documento de la universidad de san
paolo que viene a demostrar que el
gobierno federal es directamente
responsable de la propagación del virus
al no querer cerrar el país en
cuarentena para no parar la economía
sabemos que la semana que viene va a ser
muy intensa a los tres ex ministros de
salud van a tener que comparecer el más
esperado es luís enrique bande está el
primer ministro de sanidad un médico que
en muchas ocasiones avisó a bolsonaro
del peligro de la pandemia de todos los
riesgos que venían y que tuvo finalmente
que ser dimitido por sus diferencias con
el presidente de brasil también muy
esperado eduardo para suelo el último
ministro general de cuatro estrellas que
va a ser escuchado especialmente por la
crisis del oxígeno en manaus a
principios del año cuando hubo un
verdadero colapso sanitario
valeria muchas gracias por este completo
reporte con esa perfecta postal de la
bahía de guanabará y en río de janeiro
actualizamos las cifras para conocer
cómo está la situación y cómo cierran la
semana la vacunación en la región de
américa del norte el extremo norte de
nuestro continente en total la región en
conjunto lleva 171 millones 90 mil dosis
inoculadas en la región y por supuesto
en el mundo entero eeuu pues está
liderando la vacunación con 143 puntos
79 millones de dosis aplicadas le sigue
méxico con 12 millones de dosis y cierra
a canadá con 12.5 millones de dosis
inoculadas mexico tal vez tiene ya un
poco para el cierre un poco más para el
cierre de estas semanas son cifras para
el cierre de esta semana
ya que estamos hablando de eeuu allí las
autoridades indicaron que quienes ya han
sido vacunados contra el kobe 19 pueden
quitarse la mascarilla en los espacios
abiertos siempre y cuando haya poca
concurrencia sin embargo las autoridades
reiteraron que el uso de tapabocas
seguirá siendo muy necesario cuando se
presenten aglomeraciones o cuando usted
esté en lugares cerrados esta medida se
va a mantener hasta tanto la vacunación
en ese país sea completamente
generalizada
así luce la nueva normalidad en eeuu el
uso de tapabocas dejó de ser obligatorio
en espacios abiertos para personas
completamente vacunadas contra el coi 19
siempre y cuando no se encuentren en
multitudes
cities email por ganas hoy temprano los
cdc hicieron un anuncio importante a
partir de hoy si está completamente
vacunado y está al aire libre y no entre
una gran multitud ya no necesita usar
máscara ahora quiero ser absolutamente
claro si estás entre una multitud como
en un estadio o en una conferencia o en
un concierto aún necesitas usar una
máscara incluso si estás afuera y
ventilarse
más del 42% de los 328 millones de
habitantes de eeuu ha recibido al menos
una dosis de la vacuna según datos de
los centros para el control y la
prevención de enfermedades el 28.5 por
ciento de la población está
completamente vacunado sin embargo las
autoridades sanitarias recordaron que no
se eliminará por completo la orden de
usar mascarillas hasta que se alcance la
vacunación generalizada se espera que la
medida incentive a los escépticos a
vacunarse
soy optimista de que la gente utilizará
esta información para asumir la
responsabilidad personal de protegerse a
sí misma y proteger a los demás y espero
que anime a la gente a vacunarse por
completo un paso hacia adelante para la
unión americana epicentro de la pandemia
de kobe 19 y que deje escenas
desgarradoras en varias ciudades en
marzo de 2020 los sistemas sanitarios de
ciudades como nueva york y los ángeles
colapsaron en los estados de california
texas y arizona los hospitales estaban
quedando sin oxígeno a principios de
2000 21 eeuu atravesaba su peor momento
ya que los contagios ascendían entre
250.000 y 300.000 por semana sin embargo
la vacunación ha hecho posible que los
números de caigan abismalmente contando
con un aproximado de 55 mil casos nuevos
por semana desde enero de 2020 cuando se
registró el primer caso de kobe 19 se
han reportado más de 32 millones de
contagios y 572 mil víctimas mortales
y el alto número de contagios en costa
rica con cifras superiores a los 2.700
casos a lo largo de esta semana llevó a
que el gobierno instaurar a medidas más
estrictas para disminuir los contagios
de otra parte también perú rompió
récords a lo largo de esta semana al
tiempo que hay novedades en torno a la
salud del ex presidente martín vizcarra
diagnosticado con kobe 19 sin de regidor
desde san josé y francisco zacarías
desde lima nos cuentan cómo está el
panorama en costa rica y en perú en el
siguiente reporte expresa
más de 8.200 muere exposición en abril
como el mes más mortal desde que se
inició la pandemia del coi 19 en perú
según datos oficiales en medio de la
ocupación de camas al 97% de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos los
contagios siguen creciendo la
estadística del ministerio de salud
contabiliza alrededor de un millón 800
mil los casos positivos y registra en
más de 61.000 las muertes por el
coronavirus un dato anecdótico es lo
sucedido con el expresidente de martín
vizcarra y su esposa ellos fueron
vacunados irregularmente con la vacuna
contra el coi 19 sin embargo dieron
positivo al patógeno el exmandatario y
su esposa están aislados en su casa bajo
supervisión médica otro político que
encendió la alerta es el candidato
presidencial pedro castillo quien tuvo
kobe en enero pasado pues bien el
castillo fue internado de emergencia en
una clínica tras ser sometido a pruebas
de descarte los médicos le
diagnosticaron infección en la garganta
después de salir de la clínica pedro
castillo anunció la continuación de su
campaña política
si costa rica vive el momento más
crítico en toda la pandemia durante la
última semana casi todos los días hay un
nuevo récord de casos diarios
registrados son más de 2.000 casos
nuevos por día y las autoridades temen
que llegaremos a registrar hasta cuatro
mil uno de los sistemas de salud más
robustos del mundo ha llegado al tope de
su capacidad dijo esta semana el
presidente de la comisión nacional de
emergencias la unidad de cuidados
intensivos tiene un 94 por ciento de su
ocupación y algunos especialistas
proyectan un colapso inminente del
sistema sanitario las autoridades buscan
aumentar las capacidades reasignan camas
para la atención comida pero ello
implicará sacrificar la atención a
pacientes con otras enfermedades el
gobierno tomó la decisión de ampliar la
restricción vehicular ya establecida y
cerrar los negocios de atención al
público no esenciales por una semana del
3 al 9 de mayo en la región central
donde se da el 68 por ciento de los
casos las clases que habían retornado
bajo una modalidad combinada continuarán
teniendo los encuentros presenciales
nuestros corresponsales informándonos
desde costa rica y desde perú ahora nos
vamos hasta colombia porque este país
vivió una semana de récords de contagios
de alta ocupación hospitalaria y de
varios días de manifestaciones
ciudadanas que generaron multitudinarias
concentraciones de personas que han
dejado de lado el distanciamiento social
e incluso el uso de la mascarilla vamos
a conocer más detalles con santiago
ariztía desde la redacción de france 24
allí en la ciudad de bogotá
santiago hablemos del ritmo de contagio
no da tregua en colombia las cifras
siguen siendo muy altas cuál es la
situación que se registra
hola santiago bueno esta nueva ola de
contagios en colombia sigue afectando
muy gravemente al país de hecho el
propio ministerio de salud colombiano
confirmó el fallecimiento de 505
personas y se completa así entonces más
de 10 días consecutivos con más de 400
muertos diarios y esto eleva entonces el
total de fallecidos a más de 73 mil
personas recordemos que en poco más de
un año de pandemia cabe destacar
santiago que también es sumamente
crítica la cantidad de personas que a
diario son diagnosticadas con
coronavirus hasta 17.000 nuevos casos al
día son confirmados lo que eleva a 2
millones 841 mil el total de personas
contagiadas en colombia y este rápido
incremento en el número de casos
mantienen por supuesto bajo presión al
sistema hospitalario del país desde hace
ya más de unas semanas las unidades de
cuidados intensivos están al borde del
colapso el propio ministerio de salud
colombiano calcula que cerca del 70% de
las grandes ciudades del país pasan por
este pico epidémico producto de una
combinación de factores
a ver hablemos primero está por un lado
la reactivación económica de manera
masiva en segundo lugar está también lo
que fueron las reuniones sociales y
familiares particularmente recordemos
durante semana santa y cuyos contagios
comienzan a darse a conocer recién ahora
además hay que mencionar santiago lo que
es la circulación en el país de la
variante brasileña y británica además el
propio presidente iván duque dijo en su
programa de televisión diario que
colombia estaba en las semanas más
desafiantes de la pandemia
santiago eso en cuanto al contagio y a
los fallecidos que se han registrado en
las últimas horas o en los últimos días
allí en colombia que hay de la ocupación
de las salas de cuidado intensivo y que
hay de las medidas que están adoptando
las autoridades en este país era mucho
más que evidente esas discrepancias
entre la autoridad nacional el
presidente y el ministro y las
autoridades locales que trataban de
mitigar el impacto en sus respectivas
regiones y pues prácticamente tenían que
esperar a que el gobierno nacional les
diera algún tipo de autorización ahora
ha habido un poco más de uniformidad y
por lo menos un poco más de agilidad
las autoridades a la hora de tomar algún
tipo de medidas
bueno el pasado 29 de abril bogota a la
capital colombiana alcanzó el 90 y 1.4
por ciento de ocupación de las salas de
cuidados intensivos es decir estamos
hablando de unas mil 852 camas que
estaban ocupadas y ante este panorama
las autoridades de la capital tras una
reunión del comité epidemiológico
nacional decretaron la alerta roja
general para toda la ciudad y fue puesta
en marcha la denominada fórmula cuatro
por tres esto serían santiago cuatro
días de trabajo con restricciones no
dependiendo esto del último número de la
cédula de identificación y toque de
queda nocturno y además tres días de
confinamiento estrictos de viernes a la
madrugada hasta el lunes algo que
preocupa a santiago es que muchas de las
manifestaciones masivas de esta semana
que tuvieron lugar a lo largo de todo el
país hubo asistentes que marcharon y que
no cumplieron con el uso de los
tapabocas tampoco mantuvieron el
distanciamiento social físico de dos
metros que es necesario y esto por
supuesto podría derivar en muchos más
contagios vamos ante hablar ahora de
medellín la segunda ciudad
del país allí la situación sigue siendo
crítica y la ocupación de las ucis se
mantiene cercana al 98 punto 29 por
ciento y similares el caso del
departamento del valle del cauca y su
capital la ciudad de cali que alcanzó el
94.8 por ciento de la ocupación de las
ucis la verdad es que el escenario es
muy parecido prácticamente en todas las
regiones del país santiago que han
adoptado medidas o que han endurecido
las que ya tenían no para mitigar el
impacto de la tasa de contagios
santiago yo aprovecho para actualizar
aún más las cifras porque en la app
corona up que es una aplicación que
diseñó el ministerio de salud de
colombia y el gobierno para estar
actualizando diariamente las cifras
relacionadas con la pandemia y también
para que los ciudadanos reporten si
tienen algún tipo de síntomas incluso es
la aplicación necesaria para hacer los
vuelos domésticos dentro de colombia
todos los pasajeros que vayan a abordar
un avión tienen que tener esta
aplicación porque allí se genera se hace
un reporte de salud y también se genera
un código qr el caso la cifra de casos
confirmados llega a 2 millones 840 mil
34 casos de buey para el cierre de la
semana 17 mil 308 nuevos casos las
muertes hasta el momento en colombiana
lo decíamos que ha habido récords a lo
largo de toda la semana y por eso llama
mucho la atención el caso colombiano 73
mil 230 personas han fallecido hasta el
momento como vemos santiago entonces los
cuidados y las medidas como el uso del
tapabocas el distanciamiento sigue
siendo las medidas principales para
evitar el contagio pero también la
vacunación y allí en colombia está
avanzando un poco más lento que dicen
las autoridades
1 santiago el gran anuncio sin lugar a
dudas vinculados con este tema lo hizo
el propio gobierno para el cierre de
esta semana y es que a partir del 20 de
abril comenzó ya la vacunación para los
mayores de 60 años en toda colombia
estamos hablando santiago del sector de
la sociedad en el que hay que decirlo se
concentra la mayor cantidad de casos
mortales por coronavirus esta medida se
espera que beneficie a unos 2.500.000
colombianos
recordemos que el país ha recibido hasta
el momento 8 millones 77 mil dosis de
vacunas contra el virus del cob y 19
producidas por facer sinovac y
astrazéneca según lo confirmó el propio
departamento administrativo de la
presidencia pero santiago tal parece que
el plan de vacunación en colombia podría
tener un impulso en los próximos días
tras la llegada de tres nuevos envíos de
vacunas por parte de astrazéneca a
través del mecanismo kóvacs colombia
recibió un lote de 900 12 mil dosis
dos días después llegaron al país un
millón de dosis de la vacuna de sinovac
seguido de un lote de 500 49 mil 900
dosis pero de facer
estos nuevos lotes
en colombia comenzar la etapa 3 del plan
de vacunación y esto será a partir de la
tercera semana de mayo y esto por
supuesto después de una segunda etapa
que durante el mes de abril tuvo
recordemos muchas dificultades que
llevaron incluso a aplazar la vacunación
por escasez de dosis gracias a santiago
por este reporte desde bogotá
complemento su información diciendo que
colombia ha abierto la posibilidad para
que compañías privadas vean la
posibilidad de adquirir vacunas para
comercializarlas de forma gratuita entre
los colombianos una de esas vacunas para
hacer distribuir a posiblemente entre
los privados es la vacunas rusas public
be están en negociación dado que
astrazéneca y otras de las farmacéuticas
ya dijeron que no iban a comercializar a
través de los privados solamente lo
harían a través de entes públicos
también los delegados de la firma
johnson y johnson que están produciendo
la vacuna ginseng que ha tenido algunos
problemas por información de trombos en
algunos de los pacientes han llegado a
colombia para ver la posibilidad de su
comercialización sería una vacuna de
fácil uso para las autoridades
colombianas sobre todo en las zonas más
remotas porque es de una sola dosis para
qué
generar inmunización entre las
poblaciones más apartadas en la selva
del amazonas y también en las zonas del
pacífico que tienen difícil acceso a
hospitales de gran tamaño vamos a
cambiar el tema dejamos el caso de
colombia hablamos
ahora de anuncios internacionales la oms
advirtió que la lucha para frenar la
pandemia del joven 19 no debe librarse
en detrimento de los esfuerzos para
combatir a otras enfermedades como polio
y el sarampión que son patologías
mortales y que afectan sobre todo a la
población infantil y que se pueden
prevenir la brecha generada a raíz de la
pandemia de kobe 19 pone en potencial
riesgo la salud de más de 220 millones
de personas en el mundo entero
principalmente en zonas de escasos
recursos como algunos países africanos
también algunos países de américa latina
y del sudeste asiático principalmente
como ya lo decíamos en países que son
menos favorecidos naciones unidas-
quiere tratar este problema con una
campaña de inmunización masiva de cara
al año 2030
mientras el mundo concentra sus
esfuerzos en la vacunación para frenar
la expansión del nuevo corona virus la
oms advierte que millones de niños están
expuestos a la contracción de otras
enfermedades tan mortales como evitables
sobre todo en áfrica levas así existe
que a pesar que las vacunas contra el
coi 19 nos dan esperanza al final del
túnel la pandemia ha provocado múltiples
perturbaciones en los servicios de
inmunización alrededor del mundo round
the world
y nuevos datos de la ong se muestran que
como resultado del 1960 campañas de
inmunización están actualmente
suspendidas en 50 países fifty countries
esto significa que cerca de 228 millones
de niños son vulnerables actualmente a
enfermedades prevenibles tales como el
sarampión la fiebre amarilla o la polio
nis la mls yellow fever en polio
segúnla o ms de las 60 campañas pausadas
casi la mitad son contra el sarampión
una de las patologías más contagiosas y
que causa una mayor mortalidad infantil
desde hace 50 años se dispone de fármaco
para prevenirla
en 2016 el 85% de los niños y niñas del
mundo recibieron la vacuna antes de
cumplir un año
naciones unidas- indica que esta
inmunización generalizada salvó más de
20 millones de vidas entre 2000 y 2016
pero desde entonces los casos han vuelto
a aumentar
incluso antes de la pandemia ya estamos
perdiendo terreno en la lucha contra las
enfermedades infantiles evitables
20 millones de niños y estaban quedando
fuera de una vacunación necesaria y
situaría al sarampión y la polio en la
cabeza de mi lista
y ahora un año después del inicio de la
pandemia de kobe 19 seguimos perdiendo
terreno para revertir la tendencia la
oms anunció una nueva estrategia de
vacunación mundial con la que pretende
reducir a la mitad de 20 a 10 millones
la población infantil que no reciben
ninguna vacuna y salvar así 50 millones
de vidas para 2030
y volvemos a hablar de eeuu a este país
informó que 100 millones de personas ya
han sido completamente inmunizadas lo
que equivale a cerca de un tercio de la
población de ese país más de la mitad de
los estadounidenses ya han recibido al
menos una de las dosis de la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 a pesar de este
rápido avance en el proceso de
inmunización la unión americana se va a
blindar y a partir del próximo martes
empezará a restringir los viajes desde
india debido al creciente número de
contagios por kobe 19 sólo durante la
última jornada de este país asiático
reportó más de 386 mil nuevos casos un
nuevo récord por tercer día consecutivo
mientras tanto las ayudas han comenzado
a llegar a este país asiático que se
encuentra sumida en una profunda crisis
con hospitales crematorios completamente
desbordados por la pandemia y sobre todo
con escasez de medicamentos de
medicamentos y escasez de oxígeno además
ya en algunas regiones en algunos de los
estados que forman la india han sido ya
reportados algunos casos de la variante
de ese país la variante india que
también ha sido reportada
en 17 países alrededor del mundo y por
eso varios estados como ya lo
mencionamos de eeuu también está a
italia y francia han comenzado a
prohibir los vuelos y a prohibir la
entrada de personas que hayan estado en
india en los últimos 15 días para evitar
que esta variante llegue a sus
territorios en un momento en que francia
italia por ejemplo en el continente
europeo están comenzando sus procesos de
apertura de cara a la temporada de vida
del verano veamos cuál es la situación
llegaron los primeros envíos de ayuda
médica estadounidense a india el viernes
este avión militar descargó más de 400
botellas de oxígeno así como otros
equipos hospitalarios en nueva delhi
mientras el país se enfrenta a una
crisis sanitaria sin precedentes en
muchas regiones los hospitales se están
quedando sin camas oxígeno y
medicamentos buscaban
incluso la máscara de oxígeno y las
mangueras que se conectan a la bombona
son muy difíciles de encontrar
me pasé días para encontrarlas también
hay escasez de médicos no pudimos
encontrar un médico para tratar a mi
padre todos los médicos locales son
positivos al coronavirus entonces vemos
vídeos en youtube sobre cómo administrar
el oxígeno china también se une a la
cooperación internacional para india el
viernes
beijing cuyas relaciones con nueva delhi
son tensas declaró que envió más de
26.000 respiradores y casi 3.800
toneladas de material médico y
medicamentos
en los próximos días se seguirán
enviando más recursos contra la pandemia
en índia para apoyar los esfuerzos
antihéroe de micos de este país de más
de 40 países se han comprometido a
enviar ayuda médica para salvar vidas en
india en total las promesas de ayuda
incluyen casi 550 instalaciones de
producción de oxígeno 17 camiones
cisterna químicos y miles de dosis de
vacunas y es que a pesar de ser el mayor
productor de vacunas del mundo india no
tiene suficientes reservas para hacer
frente a la segunda ola de infecciones
en medio de esta crisis
mumbai anunció el viernes que se veía
obligado a cerrar sus centros de
vacunación durante tres días por falta
de dosis
y en nuestra sección en redes veamos
otras noticias destacadas a lo largo de
esta semana aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa comenzamos con esta publicación
de nuestra página web france24 puntocom
eeuu ofrecerá hasta 60 millones de dosis
de la vacuna astrazéneca a otros países
así lo dio a conocer la secretaria de
prensa de la casa blanca james aquí
quien confirmó que debido a la
disponibilidad de estas vacunas de esta
farmacéutica en particular podrán más la
producción que están teniendo podrán
enviarlas a otros países que necesiten
darle impulso a sus programas de
vacunación nacional y que necesiten
inmunizar rápidamente a sus ciudadanos
ya hemos visto que eeuu ha enviado
algunos lotes de vacunas a mexico y
también a su vecino canadá precisamente
nos vamos un poco más al norte a la
provincia canadiense de ontario que pide
la intervención del ejército para para
hacer frente al repunte de la pandemia
también la ayuda de la cruz roja fue
solicitada ante el rápido aumento de
contagios de kobe 19 y la saturación de
los hospitales
esa provincia la decisión permitirá
entonces que las fuerzas armadas envíen
de forma inmediata a personal
especializado en particular trabajadores
sanitarios a las unidades de cuidados
intensivos de las diferentes ciudades de
esa provincia
toronto en particular que es la capital
de esa provincia la provincia de ontario
y de hecho es la ciudad más poblada de
más grande de canadá es también por
supuesto la más castigada por la tercera
ola de contagio que se está viviendo en
ese país
y seguimos con la pandemia de kobe 19 se
está acelerando así lo advirtió la ope s
las cifras o las cifras de la última
semana que les hemos presentado
precisamente aquí en el programa de kobe
19 la semana en américa indican que la
pandemia está tomando velocidad por lo
que el acceso equitativo a las vacunas
ya las medidas efectivas de prevención
son cruciales para ayudar a cambiar el
curso de contagio disminuir el número de
personas contagiadas y así dar un poco
de respiro a las salas de cuidados
intensivos y a los hospitales y por
supuesto al personal de salud que lleva
un año combatiendo la pandemia de cobain
19 sin detenerse a lo largo y ancho de
todo el planeta en estos primeros cuatro
meses del año américa latina ha visto lo
peor de la pandemia hasta ahora si lo
comparamos con el año 2020
y antes de despedirme quiero hacerles un
recuento de las cifras globales para el
cierre del programa los casos totales de
kobe 19 según reporta la universidad
johns hopkins es de 150 millones 959 mil
297 casos reportados también el total de
personas fallecidas hasta el momento es
de 3 millones 175 mil 429 personas
fallecidas y el coronavirus kobe 19 está
presente ya en 192 países o regiones
alrededor del mundo eeuu es el país que
sigue liderando este conteo de contagios
y de fallecidos con 32 millones 342 mil
una cifra redondeada le sigue india
brasil que es el primero de
latinoamérica con 14 millones 659 mil
casos y finalmente cierra este top 5
rusia con esto por el momento los dejo y
nos vemos la próxima semana aquí en kobe
19 la semana en américa gracias por su
sintonía sigan con france 24
[Música]